Yeah.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's Bill Burr it's time for the Thursday afternoon?
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
Ah,
just checking in on you.
I'm checking in on you by do,
do,
do the check in Aa and all you.
Yeah.
Fuck
[inaudible]
whew.
Cares if your nose is fucking Ryan.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's so fucking clean.
X,
Eh,
you have some fun and sorry,
I'm so sick of being sick.
Just when the fuck is this gonna end.
I woke up Bodu do,
I had a fucking coffin fit that like four in the morning and uh,
you know,
it was upstairs.
I've been banished upstairs.
You know what I mean?
Like back in the day when people had like tuberculosis after the slumlord stuck
them in some damp,
dark fucking apartment for years and years and years.
And then he's poor.
Fucking tenants would die.
A lonely death and then they'd build a statue statue to the fucking slum.
Lord.
My name is subway stop after him.
You know,
what was that one on?
Off The six,
the fuck,
I can't remember the name of the Stop I used to get off at all the time.
And walk over to the fucking,
I remember everything I saw in New York.
I just,
anybody at a statue.
I just started looking them up on the Internet,
but it was all this shit that they did.
But if you went to about page three of four,
it was the other stuff that they did.
Oh yeah.
Um,
people,
if I live long enough,
I'm going to do a show this weekend at the Fox theater in Atlanta,
Georgia.
And then you know what I'm going to do then following day,
you know what I mean?
Go on and do what bill?
Yeah,
I'm getting in a fucking rental car and I'm driving over to fucking Talladega
and I'm going to go watch a bunch of fucking rednecks watching their dream cars
going around the track.
One more time.
One more fucking time.
Hey,
you stock car racing going to change.
Now that Ford is fucking phasing out all of their sedans.
Did you guys see that?
They're not making any cars anymore.
They're going to still have the Mustang,
you know,
cause what would have fucking tourist rent when they come to la?
You got to get the Red Mustang convertible and put the fucking top down and
drive around like a dose,
right?
Oh,
do you know what you want to hear?
You want to hear some self-involved Shit.
They're always talking about the millennials.
You know what I mean?
You ask a millennial,
what's the top fucking social issue out there today?
And they'd say lack of self service,
you know,
in a tunnel.
No,
actually they said climate change and they're determined to tackle the issue.
That's what I just read today.
Millennials think that climate change is the number one social issue.
Of course it is.
They are 100% right.
God bless them and they're determined to tackle it.
You know,
wait till they get a little bit of debt under their belts.
Wait to those banker cuts,
costs,
get them under their fucking,
you know,
get a run on the wheel.
Yeah,
no wait,
did I get married?
Yeah.
Wait to that APP.
And so you start getting fucking Nag.
Then your priority becomes paying off my fucking house and fucking redoing the
garage.
So I got a place for myself.
But until then,
until that all right,
you saved the polar bears.
I hope you do it.
I hope you stick to help you keep it real,
man.
Like whenever you see an old hippie still rock the long fucking,
you know hair.
Do you mean if he went bald?
Still has it all gathered in the back,
you know?
Um,
anyways,
what the fuck was I going?
I was,
God dammit.
Bility a tangent.
So something I was going to talk about there.
What I brown was talking about cold medicine being sick.
Yeah.
Led me to the cars.
Talladega.
Ah,
fuck.
If I know,
I don't fucking know.
All I know is that I've been sick too fucking long and I've had this fucking
thing started Wednesday of last week.
These are these new super colt because everybody takes antibiotics and
everything,
right?
And rather than killing the virus,
all you do is slap it around a little pit and it toughens up.
You know what I mean?
It's like,
oh,
that,
you know,
it starts to know your tendencies.
He leads with the left fucking jap always follows it with an overhand right.
Okay.
He doesn't like when you crowd them in the ring.
Oh Shit.
Somebody calling me.
Oh,
it's my mother,
a mom.
I'm doing my podcasts.
Let me call you right back.
All right.
MMM.
Anyways.
Um,
fuck.
I don't even want him talking about it anymore.
Oh yes.
Oh,
notice.
So I woke up at like four in the morning,
just fucking hacking or hacking away and um,
you know,
upstairs in the guest room,
that's where I've been,
you know,
sent my wife is also sick,
but she gets to stay in the big bed.
Do you see how that works?
You know what,
the Nice fucking master bathroom right next door,
she has a fucking humidifier going.
Just got her fucking Kleenex with the,
uh,
you know,
you won't get a sore noise.
Knows fucking missed autumn.
I'm up in the fucking guest room,
you know,
with all my drawer,
my old drum DVDs and shit blow my nose with toilet paper.
It's how it works,
you know,
and you are,
what do you see?
All you see is women just constantly complaining about the way the way men treat
women and their position in society.
Right.
So as a society,
right.
What about me?
What about my existence?
Yeah.
Where's my ribbon?
Where's my Hashtag?
[inaudible]
okay.
How come I can't get somebody fired?
You know,
I'd actually been winning arguments lately with my wife.
It's been good.
You know,
it's caused her to kind of like,
yeah.
You know,
do a couple things around the house that I've been asking her to do,
but I know it's going to go back the other way.
Same Way.
Like she goes,
see you got to watch your temper and then for a few days I walk around smiling
like Aluna tech before I go back to who I am.
But you know,
I accepted for who she is.
All right.
That's what you have to do after awhile.
Yeah.
All you ladies out there,
you think he could have changed your man?
You're not,
you're not going to change them.
The best you can hope to do is break his spirit.
Okay.
If that,
if that's what gets you off.
What about all of that shit?
Yeah.
I've about a ribbon for all the broken men out there.
I don't know why I'm talking about all of this shit.
It just fucking,
it always makes me laugh.
Um,
anyways,
how about those bro wins.
Here we go bro.
And say,
and we go bump up.
Wow.
Did I think we were going to lose that game seven now when we started our fourth
fucking line and immediately gave up a goddamn goal,
I was like,
wow,
that reminds me of certain,
somebody not starting to game crying before the Super Bowl.
The fuck are we doing right?
And we tie it up.
Then we go ahead.
All right.
It was two to one and we scored on right before the first fucking period ended
or something
that was like,
oh boy,
it's three to to look at that.
That's what I was,
it was one,
nothing them.
Then one,
one us,
and then they immediately fucking scored like they always did and then we
fucking,
and we went up three to two and I'm like,
okay,
maybe,
you know,
whatever.
And then they score off to fucking goals throughout five to three.
Okay.
This is one thing I've noticed about the Bruins.
We don't hit anybody.
Finally started hitting somebody in the third period.
But Jesus Christ,
when the other team is faster than you,
you suppose to add them to try to slow up doubt
given away too much fucking space.
I thought,
you know,
I thought Anderson looks shaky in the first period,
so I was like,
let's pepper him with some shots there in a second.
And uh,
we barely got a shot on him.
It felt so I thought that allowed them to settle down what Jesus Christ was
Iraq.
Yeah,
I tell you,
you hate to see it yet to see it.
It fell it fellow fellow ginger,
you know,
fuck it as a game like that,
I guess toward crew gives a little bit screened.
But uh,
he left,
he let up a fucking softy.
That next one would have.
Goal number five was a softy and also one of the first three wasn't a good one
either.
Um,
okay.
Not to put it all on him.
Uh,
but anyways,
my condolences to fucking Toronto may police and Jesus Christ,
you know,
and you gotta give it up to the ones that still have the heart to fucking go
down to maple leaf square,
whatever the fuck they call it.
And stand there knowing that their joy is eventually going to turn to anger.
Yeah.
And then they could just come be part of a fucking reaction video.
A bad one.
But you have to go right.
There's a leafs fan.
You gotta go.
Cause one of these times you're going to fucking win.
I liked what that one guy in the leafs said.
He said,
obviously it sucks,
but I think in the future we're going to be a team to be reckoned with.
I always love that expression team to be reckoned with.
They think they're going to be mmm.
You know,
full freckle settles down a little bit.
They get a little more playoff experience.
I'll tell you what the Bruins need.
They need a physical presence in front of the net
each day.
You know,
we still haven't made up for fucking Luke Cheech departure.
There's no,
we always had that runaway fucking train that would just flatten people.
Actually we used to have like three of them.
We just don't have that anymore.
Now we're fucking fast as shit.
At least I thought we were until we played the maple leafs.
Um,
anyway,
so now the Bruins move on.
We got to Tampa Bay lightning,
part of that fair to hockey fans down there.
I went to Tampa Bay lightning game down there,
right.
And went with four [inaudible].
We were sitting there and there was,
he's a Florida northern Florida rednecks behind is some of my favorite rednecks.
I like rednecks,
you know.
Um,
there was not a fix shit I'll fix it.
Ain't going to fit but a,
it'll hang off Nass.
Um,
we were sitting there and they add on the diamond vision.
They put this little baby up there,
right.
You know,
they had an infant up on the screen.
The guy behind us goes,
look,
I had a little baby.
I don't know why they just stuck with us a little rest of the road trip.
You drive it over to fucking Orlando dead silence in the car.
And the forest just be like,
yeah,
hello baby
little baby.
MMM.
It was hilarious.
And then also scary,
just listen to that guy cause he didn't sound real bright.
And just the fact that you know,
his TJ's can also make babies.
I just wished that like your level of intelligence made you also like,
like your Iq should be the same level as your,
a reproductive like a potency.
Is that the right word?
Like if you're a fucking moron,
it should be a half court shot that you're gonna get somebody knocked up.
You know,
that's not how it works.
Dumb people usually have like that.
Super Jealous,
you know,
let me just stand next to somebody and they get fucking pregnant.
Just shooting out fucking kids.
Uh,
that's cause they're too dumb to plan.
You know,
they just lay it on the back.
What feels good?
Feels good.
Well I was my belly sticking out.
Why is my belly moving?
Does anybody else feel weird?
Are for that meal and then they just fucking shit the kid out on a sofa.
I mean,
that happens.
That's still happens in America out there.
On the Appalachian trail.
God knows Hollywood.
We'll go out there and put some cameras on it and turned it into a fucking
reality show.
And next thing you know,
we're buying it and there's fucking little kids sewing together.
Tee shirts with these fucking dopes faces on it.
Yeah.
All right.
And that's what's wrong with this goddamn country.
MMM.
Jesus Christ.
I love all these people taking the bait on that fucking Kanye West.
Shit.
He obviously has an album coming out.
You fucking morons.
Relax.
Has he lost his mind?
Okay.
Did you learn anything with that beyond say album?
Well,
she was acting like she was all annoyed with Jay z and that there were all these
problems at all.
What the fuck?
Everybody just starts gossiping and everybody buys the fucking album and they're
still together.
Yeah.
How many fucking times you're going to jump on the hook.
He's obviously recording the fucking album.
There's no more MTV.
Billboards are a lot of fucking money.
Why don't you just start saying some crazy shit that makes no fucking sense.
You know?
And then people will listen to your next album.
Yeah.
I'm going to fucking do that.
Get my podcast numbers up.
What the fuck can I,
uh,
I'm going to just start saying positive shit about women.
Yeah.
You know,
I think the real problem beyond global warming then that swirl of trash out in
the Pacific Ocean.
Even worse than Isis.
Yeah.
Oh,
I got a text message.
Ah,
I dropped the phone.
Jesus Christ.
Tiki Barber.
Pick it up though.
For Christ sake.
Yeah.
Shut this fucking thing of I think the biggest problem
beyond Isis and isis is a major problem.
I mean they're just like the Third Reich.
If the Third Reich had no planes or boats,
oh really?
Any technology,
um,
is white male heterosexuals and their micro aggression.
Um,
which is why I have decided I can't even do this because you guys are going to
fucking retweet this thing and next thing you know,
it'd be some fucking,
I don't want to get involved in that.
Okay.
I was going to say that I've,
I've decided
no,
I can't say cause because everyone's going to get all fucking upset.
It rhymes with man.
Zishan
that would be the ultimate,
right.
If you did that
be funny.
If you,
yeah,
if you did that,
like as this as a sign of solidarity with all the pain that women have been
through,
that you actually,
uh,
went through with the sex change operation and then everybody called you a hero
and then Diane Sawyer interviewed you and they made you a woman of the year.
And then after all that cleared,
all these women came forward and said,
you are grabbing ass and titties all through the 90s and two thousands,
then you'd be like,
well,
I didn't do that.
That was frank.
I'm Francis and I just feel like for me.
Right.
And then you're on the other side of the issue.
MMM.
And they'd be like,
well,
isn't frank still in there?
Yeah.
And you could be like,
well,
I left frank on that,
that fucking operating table.
I never was frank.
Frank is my white slave name given to me by my white parents.
Um,
Jesus Christ.
How much more time do I have in this fucking podcast?
I usually like doing these things,
man.
But when my fucking head is all clogged like this,
you know,
when I lay down in my slippers having to podcast with a head cold,
that's a day's work.
People.
Now I know you guys are out there doing construction.
What the fuck do people do nowadays?
Everybody air quote works from home now,
which means they're out driving around on the highways during the day cause and
fucking rush hour traffic.
You know what I mean?
Cause they saw something on Pinterest that they have to go pick up to add to
their fucking wardrobe for their party that night.
Right?
Uh,
we should go back to making our own clothes.
You should go back to that.
You make your own clothes,
you grow your own Burgers,
right?
You want to fucking Burger,
go slaughter that calf and then you figure out how to freeze the rest of that
meat.
Are you going to start this winter?
If there pilgrim,
um,
I think to somethings goes something like that's going to happen.
We're either going to regress to that after this shit hits the fan or this
illuminati stuff is true and the robots will kill all of us.
And uh,
oh wow.
That'd be amazing in the future.
Right?
This is Illuminati city.
Everybody's dead except for the Illuminati people.
Right.
And the other people that they,
they keep making,
they kept enough people,
right,
with good genes that they make fuck each other.
So they keep making babies and stuff that they can use to fucking,
uh,
you know,
as almost like a parts car,
for organs when they reach maturity.
I know this is fucked up,
right?
Um,
sorta like Westworld meets,
uh,
a guy with a head cold doing a podcast on a Thursday.
That's how I pitched this in Hollywood.
I come in,
I say hello everybody.
We do all this small talk,
but Baba Baba,
Baba,
you know,
I,
I'd read the fucking room,
I try to figure out where the laughs are going to be,
you know,
try to block out the ice cold person that do,
she was just sitting there,
you know,
fidgeting with their fucking pen.
Um,
and I would,
I would just pitch,
I pitch the hell out of it.
So anyways,
so then you have an Illuminati city.
All right.
And they feel like they've won but their actual actually prisoners because the
robots have the city surrounded,
you know,
and they still have some robots.
The older versions that are good,
you know,
that's still work with the people.
But the latest update of the one went fucking rogue and killed a couple of it
was like the first people that died other than the parts people
and like hundreds of years.
So they hit the fucking shield.
Then I got this big bubble like the Simpsons that one time.
Right?
They've got this big bubble over the fucking city and they stay in there with
the older version of the robots and they're the ones that have to try to protect
him as the fucking higher level ones are trying to figure out how to get into
the bubble.
And that's what it is.
And it's weird thing you'd have to root for these pieces of shit humans.
So then obviously what would happen is you'd have a really good looking parts
person like Ryan Gosling and he,
Hey Nia,
hi,
hi.
And he would,
uh,
he would somehow,
you know,
he'd bang like the hottest Illuminati person and she believed in him.
And then him and one of the lesser robots would then fucking
two feet,
the next level robots while freeing all the parts people and then killing the
Illuminati people.
There you go.
And you could,
you could finish the story halfway through it and then get everybody to go to
the second one.
Right.
And then all yeah,
do have to do is just show up down at comicon.
Where in an Obi wan Kenobi rope.
And I think you've got $1 billion franchise.
What do you think?
Yeah,
you liked that movie?
I love it.
What would you name that movie
bills?
Great idea for a movie.
Ah,
Jesus.
What are you doing on my phone?
I wasn't listening.
I'm texting myself.
Those pictures.
What pictures?
The pictures you took of me earlier with,
maybe that's it.
Yeah.
I had to get back to our show.
Oh,
that's right.
I forgot we had a kid
come on you guys.
You know,
so he puts 10,000 hours into that idea.
You got yourself a good fucking movie movie,
movie.
There's a lot of hacky shit in there.
You know,
it's like Westworld meets fucking Moonraker,
uh,
with a dash a happy days.
You know,
cause at some point some all fucking Ron Howard Directs Ryan Gosling stars.
He probably wouldn't do it because you already did blade runner.
Do you guys see that one?
The 20,
48 blade runner that moves movie was the shit.
MMM.
I just noticed I'd probably been coughing like every five fucking seconds on
this.
I apologize.
But I'm not going to take a cough drop.
Alright.
Cough drops if a socialist.
All right.
Anyway,
so you only like when you do an interview,
when you got to fucking show coming up,
they go bail.
So what can people expect from you are,
what are you gonna be talking about when I kind of town?
Wait,
what do you well,
I can't fucking tell you that cause then the jokes are going to be over.
Everybody's going to know what I'm going to be talking about.
What kind of fucking question is that?
You sound like you're still angry
these days.
Okay.
I'm not angry.
It's just my,
my default emotion.
I walk around relaxed and then when anything happens,
good or bad,
I get it and I don't know if it's good.
I don't get angry.
I don't know.
Hey,
we got a new advertiser.
Okay.
We somehow convinced somebody else to get on this sinking ship.
Let's see here.
From the halls of mod to zoo,
to the shores of Tripoli.
I will tie my fucking password.
All right.
Oh,
butchers box,
and we're not talking about his wife.
All right.
Butchers box.
Now these guys actually sent me a bag of fucking butchered meat and I had a
steak the other day.
I may add my wife cooked it.
Ah,
tell me I'm not running shit in my house.
I was actually sick and she's a sweetheart.
She cooked it and it was fucking delicious.
It was a giant portion.
So much that I've actually saved it for a little bit of steak and eggs later on
this week,
a butcher box delivers healthy 100% grass fed and finished beef.
I don't know what finished means.
They are.
That means they butchered it.
Free Range.
Organic chicken and heritage bread.
Pork directly.
Yeah,
to your door on a monthly basis.
Eat like you're in the Illuminati.
All their products are humanely raised.
Yeah.
Excuse me.
Could you come over here if you wouldn't mind before I butcher your you and
never ever given antibiotics or hormones.
There you go.
If you don't want your kids to hit puberty at eight butcher blocks,
butcher blocks,
butcher box,
high quality,
healthy protein you can trust.
You can shake hands with these cows.
100% grass fed and finished beef free range.
Organic chicken.
We've said this.
Heritage,
bread,
pork.
What does Rick flair out there?
That's old world pork before they bred out all of the fat
in flavor to make it the other White Meat,
Aka this is the way they were meant to be.
I gotta look up heritage bread.
Pork.
That's fascinating.
Unbelievable.
It's like a mat and a old car with matching numbers.
Unbelievable tastes as a huge different in taste between animals raised on
pasture and those fed and grain constant and concentration animal feedlot
operations.
Butcher box is changing that.
This is great.
There's more and more of these types of people.
Gotta love it.
Um,
and they offer free shipping anywhere in this,
in the 48 states,
the lower 48 Alaska.
Who's kitten home,
right?
You're fucking trapped in your own meat in Hawaii.
You a eat pineapples over 20% off plus free bacon by going free bacon by going
to a butcher box.com/bar and using the discount code.
Bar B U R.
R I tried to,
shit,
I ate the shit.
I love this shit.
I back this shit.
Put your box.com/bar.
Um,
you know,
I've got time to go to the butcher.
Use these guys.
I have to look up heritage,
bread,
pork.
Yeah.
You know,
every form of presidents always eating this shit.
Right?
Okay.
Here we go.
Heritage bread,
pork heritage,
swine definition.
It's funny when somebody uses the word swine and it's not an insult.
I fucking love pigs.
There's certain animals that I,
I,
you know,
I like all animals,
but I fucking love pigs.
Is any cooler than a little piglet running around deaf?
I like ducks.
Yeah.
I like piglets.
He moves freak me out.
Dogs are awesome cats I respect.
But you know what I mean?
Yeah.
I,
you know,
there's never any like sort of like every once in a while you meet a really cool
fucking cat.
All right.
Definitely.
But they got that Freddy Krueger claws and shit.
You know,
you turn around real quick and they'll like practice and killing you.
you catch them stock in you and shit and fucking weird.
You wake up there on your chest staring at you
like that chicken misery.
All right.
Purpose swine at better part of the American agricultural landscape since the
arrival of the new world.
Colonists.
Why do they have to go that fucking far back?
This is why I don't read books.
Moby Dick get to the fucking whale.
Sorry.
Swine indigenous to Europe were brought with immigrants during the colonization
of America.
Conventionals fucking things in a boat.
The wooden ship,
freaking the fuck out.
Riding over there with us.
Hairless monkeys knowing they're going to get killed.
Um,
and the many different types of swine they brought had provided pork,
Lard,
pest control in land improvement services for centuries.
How to pork on a pig's help with pest control cause they fucking eat everything.
Now you have something else to look up.
This is how you lose a day on the Internet because there's always an answer.
Doesn't mean it's right.
But there's also someone who will,
some will have a page.
There's what?
I think there's wires.
What they do with varmints.
Uh,
modern bread associations maintain pedigree registries of pure bred animals for
each breed that descends from these colonial,
oh wow.
These are like the fucking,
the blue bloods of pigs as well as later introductions.
A registration of animals destined to become breeding stock is essential to the
longterm security of the breeds.
Registration validates pure bred status of the animals and assures their
availability for conservation by future generations.
Many
swines but he swines Bree swine breeds that were once core components of
regional cultures are now in danger of extinction as cultures of Homo,
Homo,
generalized,
homogenized,
God,
I'm stupid.
And historic agricultural traditions abandoned the flavors and food traditions
that revolved around yet check out Monsanto for that one fucking lunatics
definition of heritage swine.
I don't even know if it's [inaudible].
They always said their fall.
People you blame,
who knows?
Allegedly Monsanto heritage swine must adhere to all of the following oh
one I ranked a true chin.
Genetic bread.
The breed is a true genetic breed of swine.
That is when made it together.
It reproduces the breed type.
All right,
I guess this is from Europe,
uh,
to de dos.
What does it ans times I,
I don't,
I can't do the German and dangered breed.
The breed is or has been endangered as defined by the livestock cons conservancy
and appears on or is recovered from the current conservancies conservation
priority list in the critically threatened Jesus Christ.
Long history in the u s pure bred.
I get it.
It's pure bread.
I like it.
There were fucking in danger and I'm eating them.
I'm meeting the fucking pig version of a fucking bald eagle.
Um,
what the fuck did I just,
I just shut that off and I,
I,
I wanted to,
what else did I want to look up?
What was it?
Oh,
how to pigs
control pass population.
Yeah.
Well eat bugs.
Not how,
how on how to bill.
How do,
okay,
here we go.
Well,
it just says,
forbid I then information was forbidden.
Practical,
feral pig control because feral pig population,
those are the wild pigs.
Anyways.
Fuck this shit.
How are their wild pigs,
by the way?
Were those the farmers that got scalped by the native Americans?
So they just stare.
Pigs just ran off.
Continue to fuck for centuries,
you know,
I dunno,
I don't have the answers to these questions,
but I do have some bullshit I have to do at 10 o'clock.
Um,
all right.
That is the podcast.
This was a weird one.
Okay.
All right.
But we came up with a good movie idea.
We learned about heritage pigs and fucking a swine
from Europe
and a Gopro Lynch and Celtics.
About those Celtics,
but I try to wrap up these Pesky fucking Milwaukee Bucks.
You know I liked that one guy on on Milwaukee.
He looks like a fucking,
like a mid size minuit both really dark skinned guy.
He hit,
he had some fucking lay up or some shit to go up by four in the second quarter
already.
Shush the crowd.
Like he just hit a game winning three does the second quarter and then they go
on to lose the game.
I just don't,
I tie,
I don't understand these kids today.
All right everybody have a great weekend.
Your content and I'll see everybody in
Atlanta and I'll see you down at the fuck race track count.
Dad got come Saturday,
listen to the music and enjoy another half hour of our greatest sets from a
Thursday just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast,
Thursday earlier this year or possibly this decade.
All right,
I'll see you.
Uh,
[inaudible].
Hey,
what's going on?
It's Bill Burger and it is the Monday morning podcast from Monday,
April 26th April,
April 26th,
2010 how the hell are you?
I'm a little late today with the podcast doing it three 43 Los Angeles time.
Uh,
and you probably want to like do what the fuck you're supposed to be doing these
Monday morning.
That's why you call it the Monday morning podcast.
So when I come to work on Monday morning,
I have something to listen to rather than focusing on the fucking job that I
hate.
Well,
you're right,
landless.
I am late this week,
but you know what,
I was busy fucking busy this week.
Uh,
I,
I was doing shit this morning,
you know what I mean?
And also not to mention I am filming this podcast for the first time ever.
I am allowing somebody else into the Monday morning podcast bunker until now.
People just had to use their imagination to wonder what the fuck does bill look
like while he does this podcast?
Is he wearing a Tuxedo,
maybe a dinner jacket?
Is he sitting there?
You know,
I'm not,
I'm in pajamas in my t shirt with my little radio shack headphones on.
Does the exact way that you pictured me,
but I am filming at this week,
um,
because uh,
my DVD is a just about complete and now we are working on extras and I think I,
my,
my last DVD I did the,
uh,
I did a little short history,
a bunch of clubs that I loved in New York.
So you kind of got that whole background and I figured out my mail do this.
Maybe I'll fill in the podcast,
edit out the hours and hours of unfunny moments,
right?
So you're going to actually hear the whole fucking podcast,
these idiots who bought my DVD who are going to watch it.
Just be like,
oh my God,
this is the greatest fucking thing I've ever seen because of the wonderful world
of editing.
So he probably thinking like,
what are you doing bill?
You filming it yourself and you're going to edit it that,
that,
that does not,
that's not consistent with the more on that I'm used to listening to where
you're right.
I'm not,
I have the wonderfully talented Brian Spitz is a working the camera.
Yep.
That was him right there.
He actually shot my failed pilot last year on comedy central.
Remember that one?
That was fun and we got excited then we were like,
it's going to happen.
It,
it grew up with,
honestly,
it was a great fucking show,
wasn't it pilots ever in the history and the history of failed pilots?
I would say we were.
Yeah,
we were,
we were in the,
you know,
we just failed as opposed to just a complete failure.
It'd be like,
you know,
have a patch.
Passing grade was 60,
I think.
I think we've got about 58 on that,
you know,
I don't know.
But you know what the weird thing is,
it's actually up on my end DB
page.
That's what I love.
I don't know who put it up there,
but you're not supposed to put shit on there that isn't on TV or wasn't released
in cinema or whatever.
And uh,
I,
for the life of me,
I don't know how to take it down,
but um,
you'll take it care.
Okay,
thank you.
Because people,
all right,
well that's cool.
Can you actually,
can you actually call imdv okay.
Yeah,
but that's not a good,
I'm going to call those guys.
I'm going to call that website and uh,
yeah,
I'll get those guys on the phone to see what's up.
So yeah.
So if you're ever wondering what the burn effect was,
that was just a working title that we gave it to him.
It never aired and it won't air and less.
I,
uh,
become hugely famous or infamous.
That's basically it.
If I become a huge movie star or television star,
you'll probably up seeing it in some form.
Or if I go to a mall and I just started fucking,
you know,
killing puppies at the local pet store or whatever the fuck you do.
I wouldn't say shooting because every,
everybody's done the shooting thing,
isn't it
khaki at this point?
You know what I mean?
That's,
it's like,
it's like if I was okay
comedian,
I went on on,
on stage and I started talking about airline food,
basically going walking in to a mall massacring people,
I think it's Hacky at this point,
you know,
Yawn.
If I can be so bold to say I'm fucking bored with that shit.
But anyways,
let's get to me and my big fucking week.
Do you guys have a big week?
Well,
if you didn't,
let me fucking tell you about my big week.
First of all,
I don't know if I've been talking about this on the podcast as I settle in
Sofa.
Um,
basically everything that identified me as the person that I am,
uh,
a month ago,
either it was expiring or I didn't have it.
You know,
I,
I basically could not prove that I existed with any sort of paper.
You know,
my passport was expiring my driver's license.
I needed to get that thing for about fucking two years.
I'm not gonna lie to you when you first moved out to Los Angeles,
I think they give you about six weeks to get it.
And I've almost been out here for three fucking years.
So,
uh,
and my New York license was expiring.
I didn't have a social security card that I could produce.
I had the number,
you know,
the Illuminati gave me a fucking number when I was eight years old.
Let's get them on the wheel.
Let's get them in debt.
Are you in college?
Are you making 200 bucks a week?
Hey,
here's a visa card.
We'll give you a $3,000 limit.
Don't worry.
Give us 25 bucks a week and just get it up to you three grand limit and we'll
fucking own your ass.
All right?
So I didn't have that.
What else didn't I have?
And My,
and my birth certificate,
I had nothing.
So I was like a,
I was like,
fuck,
I gotta handle this shit.
You know?
Cause all of a sudden now I'm doing gigs in Europe,
you know,
I think I'm going to Japan to perform for the troops.
I need pieces of paper saying I am who I am and I have not done anything fucked
up.
So a,
in one month I got my passport renewed,
I went down to the social security office,
I got that fucking thing,
I found my birth certificate and the last thing I needed was my driver's
license.
So he figured out that driver's license,
I mean that's a pain in the ass to take the fucking test.
You know,
do you ever notice like what a pussy you become as an adult when it comes to
tests?
Like I think once you don't take a test for what you're used to,
what as a kid,
people would always testing you.
You know,
we're having a spelling test,
run vocabulary tests,
some bully punches in the face.
He's testing you.
You know,
are you going to be a fucking man?
you Charles Bronson at age 12 or are you fucking a Richie Cunningham who I was
and got bullied
and sees no reason to go back to a fucking reunion now.
It wasn't that bad,
you know,
I'll be honest with you.
Uh,
when was it bad?
Maybe elementary school.
Beginning of middle school,
everybody hit their growth spurt and I didn't,
I still had a high pitch voice in a,
a an orange Afro.
That wasn't a good look.
That wasn't the look you wanted to rock is the youth says.
So anyways,
I have to take my driver's test out here.
And uh,
I brought it up with a couple of other La,
Los Angelenos and straight across the board,
everybody was telling me like they had horror in their eyes and how difficult
this fucking test was gone.
Oh my God,
dude,
it's dude,
it's fucking hot.
It's fucking hard.
They kept saying that.
I remember I always lived out here 10 years ago.
I took the test.
It wasn't fucking hard,
like don't do it.
I'm telling you dude,
it was fucking heart.
And I had this girl with this party was this,
have you been to the DMV on here?
Oh my God.
It's not like the DMV anyway out la.
It's just like if on Dale and I kept saying,
well I bended the DMV.
I've been doing it.
I know it's crowded.
And she just kept going now.
Now like you don't understand and there's nothing worse than somebody just tells
you like you don't understand.
It's like front somebody from Chicago when you're trying to tell them it was a
cold winter and then they got to go on about fucking now you don't know what
cold is until you're standing there rubbing your balls next to fucking Lake
Michigan.
You know,
like it's fucking minus 20 degrees in Boston.
But still,
that's,
you know,
my family all came from fucking the Midwest.
So anytime I had a paper,
when I bitch about the Colo,
let me tell you,
you don't know cold.
You don't go to Chicago.
Let me tell you,
go to Chicago.
You said they're all those fucking idiots.
Add some good barbecue.
I'll do,
do you don't know barbecue.
Go to fucking Texas.
That's where they got the bar.
Like,
like they're the only people who know that shit.
All right,
I've got a little upset there.
Don't hold it against me.
So anyways,
uh,
everybody's telling me I don't know what the fucking DMV is.
You know all this does,
this just motivates me to pass this fucking test in the first time so I can just
make so I can justify me judging all these la Douche bags like that.
Just mentally weak fucking people.
So I started studying the test,
get the book and it's like 90 pages.
I was like,
fuck.
All right,
whatever.
Break it down.
I'm going to do 30 pages a day.
I outlined this book.
Huh?
What are you doing right now sitting in your cubicle instead of working,
looking at your spreadsheets,
what are you doing?
I hear what I fucking outline the book.
I outlined the book 30 pages at a fucking time meticulously like Tom Hanks in
that movie when he was chasing Leonardo Dicaprio.
Catch me if you can.
I was like that,
that level of shit and I was,
I,
I just,
you know,
fucking broke the whole book down and then I sat there every day for 45 minutes
to an hour and I went over all this shit in two days before the test.
Saturday.
I actually took the sections out than I than I still was having problem with and
I just fucking went hardcore on that section.
Memorize that and went through my all my outline.
I knew the whole fucking thing.
How you want to ask me some questions?
You want to talk about parking near railroad tracks?
I got to fucking answer for you.
Seven and a half feet.
If you're inside a seven and a half feet,
you're fucked.
18 inches from the curb,
three feet from a fucking handicap ramp.
You know one of these fucking guys rolling by asking you for a quarter.
Those guys can't get and like three feet close to those guys.
15 feet from a hydrated.
You've got to start signaling a hundred feet before you make a turn.
You get into the turning lane.
You can only drive in it for 200 feet.
He can't use it as a passing lane.
I had to shit down,
so I'm like,
fuck all these people.
I walked in there confident.
I'm talking Colby Bryan,
eight seconds left.
Give me the fucking ball.
All right.
I ironed my shirt.
I knew I was getting a picture of that day for my license to be nothing but
success.
So I walk in there,
I don't know what happened immediately I start getting fucking nervous.
You know like the first time I did Letterman,
right,
like the first fucking time you do anything.
I'm,
I'm fucking get nervous.
I've taken this fucker test four different times.
Took it in Boston,
passed it.
New York pastor came out of La 10 years ago.
I passed it,
moved back to New York,
passed the thing.
Why am I fucking nervous?
Cause he's fucking Las holes.
They have voices are in my head dear dude.
He fucking hot dude.
I fucking feel,
you know I forgot to mention is they all said the same shit.
Why?
Why they failed.
It is because they didn't study the first time because I thought it was going to
be easy cause they drive every day.
Do you really tell,
just think of how stupid that statement is.
Dude,
I drive every day.
I know how to do it.
It's those little things,
you know like what is a white curb mean?
You know,
you come up and it's painted white.
What does that mean?
Loading and unloading of passengers or picking up mail,
yellow curb.
What does that mean?
Lie Loading and unloading of freight.
If you're not in a commercial vehicle,
the driver has to stay with the car.
I studied for the Shit me,
the Rock,
it's fucking going in and we're going to the next round of the playoffs.
I was ready for that shit and I went in there and I,
maybe there was just the overall anxiety,
the fucking place.
But I do the whole shit.
First of all I do,
what I always do at the DMV is I just blow off the line and I act like I didn't
see it and that I'm some sort of like,
you know,
royalty,
like I'm actually staying at the embassy for some fucking country you never
heard of.
I'm that guy.
You know when you stand in line and you followed the rules and then you get up
to the fucking cashier lady and then there's that [inaudible] he was just
standing there to the side respectively.
Half an inch just behind your peripheral.
But you know he's there and you can't have a pause in your conversation because
you know that asshole's going to jump in.
That's who the fuck I was.
And I said,
Hey,
I'm sorry buddy,
sorry.
And I wasn't sorry.
That was me really being like,
dude,
I'm interrupting you right now.
And I said,
ah,
I gotta take this,
uh,
you know,
I had a previous,
a schedule appointment,
where do I go?
They go,
you go around the corner,
whatever.
So thank the guy.
I wasn't saying thank you.
I don't know what the fuck I was doing is just trying to prevent the guy from
punching me in the face because I deserved it.
And I went over to go take the fucking test and a,
I'm standing there and they only got like this walled off area.
Okay.
This is how confident was.
I didn't even,
I didn't even brush up out in the parking lot.
I was just like,
bring this shit on.
You want me to take Lebron?
I fucking got him.
Right.
So I walk in there right.
And you got to wait til like can only allow like five people in there at a time.
So the first dude walks out and uh,
you know,
they got the black dude behind the counter,
like the host scared straight.
You need to get your shit together,
kind of do,
you know,
and I'm just sitting there going,
oh fuck,
here we go.
Here we go.
This fucking guy,
this guy's breaking hearts all day and he doesn't even give a fuck.
Look at it.
Look on his face.
He doesn't give a fuck that bill Parcells look on his face,
right?
So there's fucking Indian dude comes up and he,
and he hands him the thing and the guy just fucking puts red all over it and the
guy fails.
And then I'm like,
oh,
fuck the any guy.
These guys are fucking smart,
right?
Indian guys are smart.
They fucking answer our phones over here.
I can't answer phones.
If somebody from India called me,
you know,
give myself a fake Indian name.
These fucking people are smart.
These people were running shit until the English fucked him over,
right?
This guy fucking pass.
But then I calmed myself down.
I'm like,
wait a minute,
this is a second language.
This is his second language.
If I went to France,
could I pass the driver's test?
Fuck No.
All right,
don't compare yourself to that guy.
And then the next year came up and it was a slacker.
This white kid who had like tight jeans yet,
they were hanging off his ass and I just wanted a boot him right in his fucking
taint.
He passes.
So it gave me hope and I went in there,
I got the test,
okay,
I get eight hours sleep.
I took a deep breath and I'm like,
here we go.
I have the test right in front of me.
And the first one was some bullshit about what is the legal alcohol level.
You know that you can drive on it.
I'm like,
this is a fucking joke.
I'm going to ace this test and dude,
I'm going to tell you right now after the first question,
it just went down fucking hill.
Listen to these questions.
I'm studying all this shit about how close to park to a curve,
a curb and all that shit.
You must notify the DMV within five days.
If you sell or transfer your vehicle are cited for a traffic violation.
That's,
that's obviously no paint your vehicle a different color.
Sound like a fuck.
I didn't read that part.
I don't remember that part.
Sell a transfer your vehicle,
painted a different color.
Five days.
Sell a transfer your vehicle.
Don't you have to fucking tell them right then.
I won't.
They automatically know what the satellites,
they won't see that transaction.
Go down in the fucking driveway.
Do it.
And then this is panic just like,
and I,
and I was like,
oh my God,
what the fuck?
And I got like six questions in and I literally put the number two pencil down
and I whispered,
yell.
I went really?
As I looked at the black dude when he wasn't looking at me,
of course,
totally passive aggressive and a do it.
I'm not gonna lie to you this fucking tests.
It was brutal.
It's a fucking brutal.
Like,
you know,
usually when you take a multiple choice tests it's like there's the obvious the
half,
right?
And then the fucking ridiculous.
Like when you drink a glass of water,
should you a uh,
make sure you have enough air in your lungs
before sucking down the entire glass.
And if you do run out of air,
stop drinking,
inhale,
you know,
be smashed the glass against your head,
obvious shit,
right?
This shit was like,
when is it legal to use his cell phone?
I have the test right here without a hands free device while driving.
Okay.
When is it legal to use a cell phone without using a hands free device?
Have you got an answer?
A when making a call while stopped at a red light,
that's obviously no,
but here's the two close ones.
When making a call for emergency assistance or never,
when is it legal to use a cell phone?
Hands Free people,
hands free,
hands,
free device.
And there's all this shit on TV going if you use your cell phone and it's as bad
as fucking drinking and driving
in the book it said never.
And it said you could use it to for to make to make an emergency call after you
fucking pulled over and all that bullshit looked for somebody riding a bike,
you know,
looking for an old guy,
one of those try sickles,
all of that shit.
So this just said when making a call for emergency assistance,
it didn't say you pulled over.
It didn't say you didn't pull over.
So I fucking panic than I wrote.
Never got it wrong.
All right,
this is still,
that's fucking stories taking 10 times as long.
And how long it took me to study for the fucking test.
Long story short out of 18 questions,
I got 15 right?
Three wrong.
I fucking passed the test but I know I owe an apology to all you Los Angelenos.
This was a hard ass fucking test.
It was difficult.
I know what you're thinking like that way you guys are all talking shit because
you're relaxed right now.
Right?
We find another difficult one here.
Highways are typically most slippery.
This is a desert question cause it doesn't rain out here.
And what happens is when it doesn't rain for awhile,
oil transmission,
fluid,
and gas all starts to coagulate.
And when it rains,
it's like,
I can't say it's like ice for God knows.
People drive like it out here.
But this,
this is the question,
it says,
uh,
ah,
what the fuck was that?
Highways are typically most slippery during a heavy rainstorm in the middle of,
in the middle of summer.
All right.
Middle of the summer.
It's fucking dry out.
You know,
maybe that's it.
And then it says when it's,
when it first starts to rain after a dry spell.
Well yeah,
yeah,
after a dry spell.
Absolutely.
But the summer's dry.
What the fuck writes?
And at this point,
my Mike fucking heart rate is going like 9,000 beats a second.
And then it says after it's been raining for a long time,
if it's been raining for a long time,
the roads are wet.
It's going to still be fucking slippery.
But I know it has to do with it being dry out here.
So I fucking broke that one down.
I'm like,
all right,
it's the middle of summer.
It's a heavy fucking rainstorm.
Who's to say it didn't fucking rain heavily the day before and had already
washed all the gas off.
So then I get,
so I guessed when it first starts to rain after a dry spell and I was fucking
right,
but that's the level you had to break this shit down.
All right,
so I passed.
That's it.
They took my thumbprint,
the fucking Illuminati,
you know,
sent that right to the Rothschild's fucking house.
Do you know those sons of bitches actually have the audacity,
the Rothschilds to have a book about the giant fucking house they bought in
England off of all their fucking Shylock money from the rest of us.
Do you believe you believe the fucking balls of that?
Evidently there's something beyond your mansion.
It's called a manner.
That's when you have you,
that's when you do take like fucking 12 mansions and you put it together and
like people don't even know how to get to your house.
Like I can guarantee you something right fucking now.
Oh,
this is a great way to see if they're running shit.
You don't,
when you Google maps,
like if you Google map where the fuck I live,
not only can you see my place,
they'll probably,
you can probably see my brand new social security card.
No one gives a fuck about me.
But if you Google map the Rothschild's house,
I guarantee you it doesn't fucking show up like the Goddamn White House
because they're running shit and you know what?
They have my thumbprint on their fucking wall of the,
of their fucking nine mile wine cellar.
Does that make any sense?
Well it shouldn't because I don't read.
All right,
I'll fucking read anyways.
What else do I got going on here?
That wasn't bad.
Half for being filmed.
I didn't seem too self conscious.
Look at that.
Got a big nod.
Eyebrows up.
I think it's going good.
The first filmed Monday morning podcast.
This is what I do.
If you've been listening to this,
I'm talking to the camera right now,
not to you go back to work.
He'd been fucking off already for 19 minutes and 40 seconds.
This is what I do every week.
I sit here in my,
in my,
in my pajamas and my little footlocker tee shirt,
you know,
is this footlocker?
I don't know what the fuck this is.
Footlocker,
like 87 t shirts for like $9.
If you ever wondered if you ever wondered,
hey,
did a three year old put this shirt together or was the person at least 16 you
can never be more sure than when you go to footlocker and you buy those fucking
tee shirts.
When you get like nine of them for eight bucks,
that's guaranteed that that's not even child.
That's like toddler,
toddler,
fucking labor.
Be funnier if I could fucking say it.
So this is what I do every week.
Okay.
This is what I do.
So if you want to listen to the podcast,
go to [inaudible] dot com click on Monday morning podcast.
You hate your fucking job.
Hopefully there'll be on iTunes at this point.
They will be,
I'm going to talk shit,
they're going to be on iTunes.
You know,
I have like 14 listeners.
I'm trying to get it up to 15 whenever they,
whatever the fuck you want from me.
All right,
let's play it.
Okay,
I'm back.
I'm back doing the podcast.
Um,
all right,
let's get to the stories this week.
I,
uh,
that was the first story.
I'm just going to tell some stories this week.
I've got another one for you.
I'm at this point.
Do you want me to pause Brian and go into another room to give people something
visually different to look at?
Should I do that?
All right.
Let's try to hit pause here.
This is going to be really quick for you.
People listening at home and say,
I'm going to pause and then we're back.
So I'm pausing right now.
All right.
Yeah,
we'll put bookshelves in there.
Okay.
We're back.
We decided,
you know what?
We already tried to do this and I fucking lost the whole podcast,
so we're not doing it.
I'm recording right now.
We're just do you don't need to record this.
You don't even see me.
I'm not going to use this on the DVD.
This is just for the poor bastards at home listening.
I actually,
so that's my deal,
everybody.
I'm moving shit around my apartment right now.
This is exciting.
It's exciting to audit in an audio way to hear the it isn't.
I know it's not,
dude.
You know what?
Is there any doctors that listen to this?
How fucking arrogant is that?
Like they have time between surgery to listen to a moron like me.
Well,
a lot of doctors are arrogant anyways.
They save people's lives.
They get that God complex.
Just to let you know,
dude,
that's my water.
All right,
that's yours over there.
Okay.
Just letting you know.
I mean,
I like you when everything,
all right.
You did a great job on the pilot,
but let's,
let's keep it there.
Um,
I fucked up the arch of my foot.
I did it years ago from playing drums,
trying to get my foot as fast as John Bonham's having no fucking technique and
not having stretched so that that tendon that runs from the ball of your fucking
foot to your heel.
Every once in awhile I fuck it up and it,
and it just takes forever to heal and I don't know what I'm supposed to do about
it.
All right,
I stretch.
I got the tennis ball rubbing underneath it.
I know I'm not supposed to walk around,
but that's what I do.
Okay.
I use my feet.
A lot of people don't,
you know,
if you walk into a Mcdonald's and you see those people,
that's what they use their feet for to walk to their car to sit in their car and
then they don't even go in anymore.
They just drive right up.
So I want to know what else can I be doing?
Is there any sort of aspirin that I can be taking to get the fucking
inflammation down?
And you probably want it.
Okay.
You're,
you're probably asking me this bill because not being able to use your foot is
fucking annoying.
It goes beyond that.
Dr.
So,
and so I'll tell you what my problem is.
My problem is I'm going back east for,
for a friend of mine's daughter is graduating college and I have to go to the
graduation and uh,
I'm getting it,
getting together with some people I used to play drums with.
We used to jam with back in the day when we all thought we were going to get on
MTV and be the latest hair metal band,
the fact that you had a redhead and a hair metal band and then he could only
grow a fucking Afro right there,
should've let you know that you weren't gonna make it.
So long story short,
we're getting together and rather than going back and playing the music we
played in the 80s because that would just be too sad to go back and play my
Michelle
or whatever the fuck we used to play.
We're like,
let's do something more contemporary.
And I've always played single bass drum and I became a huge fan of Pantera and
shit.
So I go,
let's do cowboys from hell and it's got this insane double bass part.
And the second I said that Shit,
I fucked up my foot and I haven't been able to practice.
And meanwhile the guitar player,
the Bass Player,
they're all shredding,
you know,
ignoring their children.
So,
and here I am going to be the foundation of the band and my foot's fucked up.
So I need a quick remedy.
All right.
I need something.
I need something fucking quickly here.
Uh,
that,
is there anything that I can take that,
that will just,
you know,
I don't want to take roids for my foot coming there with my right foot twice as
big as the,
uh,
my left foot.
You know,
I don't need that.
Have one big Jason Gme,
Roger Clemens Foot and the other one's walking around like Willie McGee.
I don't need that shit.
All right,
tell me,
what do I take aspirin?
Aleve.
What do I take?
Come on podcast fucking free.
You can hook me up a little free medical advice.
Can you email me a prescription or that just literally,
and you're,
you're fucking days as a doctor.
All right,
let's,
let's continue on with the podcast.
As I sit here rolling a tennis ball underneath my foot.
Um,
the next thing,
oh,
here's a great story for you,
Brian.
You might like this.
Do you know I was a hero this week?
I was actually,
I did something heroic.
I have never,
I have never done anything heroic in my life.
Okay.
And believe me,
I've walked by house fires and saw people screaming saying there's a ladder
right there.
Just put it up.
And I walked away.
I walked away,
sounded like I didn't hear him.
I'm that kind of a fucking guy.
Um,
no,
this is the deal.
It was a Sunday.
And you know people go to Brunch on Sunday.
I'm like,
all right,
fuck it.
I'll go to brunch.
Right?
Remember that bit?
Huh?
Paid $18 as fast as the Wa.
Is that a specialist?
How did that bit go?
Is that as,
I thought it was pastel.
It's asparagus.
I can't remember.
So we go to brunch and a,
you know it's usual shit.
Do you want to sit inside?
You want to sit out outside as a redhead?
I'm always going inside.
Let's fucking sit inside.
I got enough freckles.
I've had enough fucking pain in my life.
Please.
Let's sit inside a,
but you know I'm always with brides cause they always want to go to brunch.
Oh it's fine.
It's too nice.
It's always fucking nice when they go to brunch.
It's never raining,
is it?
Right?
So.
All right,
let's sit outside.
So we sit outside and because I'm the gentleman,
I have to sit with my back to the road so I can brace,
you know,
and protect my girlfriend and her mom in case a bread truck comes flying in
because the guys text messaging or something,
right?
So I'm sitting there and uh,
all of a sudden I just feel it.
I just feel like something's fucking wrong and something my caveman DNA,
like when you getting stocked by a saber tooth,
tiger just kicks in and something just tells me to fucking look left.
And I look left and here comes this crazy fucking lady and I'm talking crazy.
I'm talking shutter island.
You remember that chick that shushed Leonardo Dicaprio set the second Leonardo
Dicaprio fucking reference.
There you go.
You remember that chick who shushed him and shutter island?
That's what this girl looked like,
except with sort of brownish red hair.
Okay?
It's basically one of these people who should be getting professional help is
straight up bat shit crazy.
And uh,
this just,
this state is bankrupt.
So they just let them go.
They just let these fucking people go.
You're not see Sarah McLaughlin wine and about these people come out and rescue
these fucking,
these people who are talking to telephone poles.
It's all about the dogs with her.
Her priorities are so fucked up.
It's ridiculous.
I hope she sees this.
I am so disappointed in you Sarah McLaughlin.
Huh?
When are you going to grow up and stop whining about those little pussy ass
fucking dogs?
All right.
That was mean.
All right,
let's get back to it.
So she starts coming down the street and she's like,
she looks like she's going to start fucking crying.
Okay.
Like,
and it's just one of those things,
you know,
you just feel this fucking person's going to do something and I have a feeling
they're going to do it to me.
So I,
I'm,
I'm working out my shit.
I'm like first,
fortunately the chairs where these really late wicker sorta kind of Douchey
Brunchy chairs.
So I was just going to grab the fucking chair and I was going to smash her in
the face if I didn't have time or if I had time I was going to leap to my feet
on my bad fucking foot and out like a lion tamer.
Ah,
get back.
Crazy person,
right.
Start whipping her with the fucking tulips on the Nice,
beautiful brunch table.
That's what I was going to do.
So she doesn't lunge at me,
but she walks by me and is that awful moment,
the blind spot,
you know what I mean?
Where she's not to my left,
she's not to my right.
She's right behind me and she fucking goes by me and I'm like,
thank God.
Like I was seriously fucking nervous and I look left again just to,
you know,
I don't know why I looked left again.
And then I see this fucking sad looking woman slowly following the crazy person
with this look on her face like she had been wronged.
I,
next thing I know.
Next thing I fucking know,
she's talking to the table next to us and talking to us,
talking about how that crazy woman had just walked up to her,
reached up to her sweater and just fucking ripped.
I don't know.
She had a brooch.
She just fucking took it off her chest and walked away with it.
And I'm looking at the lady and she has the lady and she has this fucking hole
in her sweater where something had clearly been ripped off.
And for the life of me,
I don't know why I immediately just got up.
I don't know why.
I have no fucking idea why I do what the fuck.
I don't do this shit.
I get up and now I'm going down the street following the shutter island lady
with no training whatsoever in this situation.
I'm literally walking and now I couldn't sit down.
I couldn't get sit down.
Like,
I have this,
this fucking Lee Marvin,
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna make shit right moment.
And then I go,
you know what?
Maybe I'll sit down and look at the biggest pussy ever.
And not only my girlfriend and my mother's there,
so I had to keep going.
So now I'm following this girl and I'm literally,
I'm fine.
Never been so fucking nervous in my life because it would have been bad enough
if we,
if it was like a crazy dude.
A crazy guy is scary,
but at least you know if,
if,
if it gets physical,
I mean,
what?
What are,
what are the rules in that?
Do you know Brian?
What did you know you can't hit a woman bought if she's crazy and she just stole
approach.
How about a jab?
It's going to get a mitt and a face like Larry Holmes.
So she doesn't see the overhand,
right.
Anyways,
I don't know what to do,
so,
but I can't go back to the table or I'm going to look like a bitch in front of
my girlfriend and my mom saw,
I'm like,
fuck,
why did I get up?
Why did I get up?
Why didn't I do?
Why didn't I say sit inside?
I wanted to sit inside,
but I didn't want to seem like a root prick in front of my girlfriend's mom.
Like I tell her what to do.
Like she says,
kept fucking woman sit down in this situation.
So I'm walking down the street and this is what I do.
She's on the sidewalk.
I'm literally in the street.
Okay.
I'm like,
is that circumnavigation I'm doing some police shit where I'm staying outside of
whatever she can throw at me scratching.
It's one of these people,
you've got to get like a tetanus shot if you roll around the ground or hepatitis
assumption.
So I'm like,
what am I going to do?
What do I do?
So I don't know what happened.
I just said I,
I basically,
I just started going,
hey,
uh,
hey sweetheart.
Hey Sweetie.
I basically,
I think I started calling her affectionate name,
some like the 1940s hey,
a fucking tall drink of water.
And I finally got her attention and she turns around and looks at me with this
crazy look with tears in her eyes.
And I just say,
ah,
I think you have something that doesn't belong to you.
And meanwhile,
it's fucking pathetic lady who just let her walk up to her to begin with.
It's like he didn't see that she was crazy.
That's why I'm in this situation.
Right.
She fucking,
she ends up walking up to the girl and when I said,
I think you have something that doesn't belong to you,
she just sort of looked at me and like in slow motion,
lifted up her left arm and she had this green pea soup look and sweater on and
she had the brooch pin to like just right around her wrist and she just held it
up.
So at this point I'm like,
I'm not touching this bitch.
So I let the,
the,
the fucking victim lady with the sad puppy dog eyes,
she comes in and I'm basically sitting there like an NHL ref with respect for
two goons that are about ready to go at it.
Right.
And I'm just going to jump in when I see that I can jump into,
stop this,
this fight that's going to happen without getting hit myself.
And uh,
so anyways,
the lady starts UNP unpinning the brooch and the whole time she's,
she basically followed my lead by being nice.
She just kept going.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
I really appreciate this.
And she couldn't get the fucking thing off.
It was like one of those action movies with like the clock's going down for the
bomb and I'm sitting there going lady and my head,
I'm like,
would you get that fucking brooch off this crazy bitches arm?
And I just kept looking at her right hand cause I knew at some point she was
either going to gouge your eye out,
just do some crazy shit,
right?
Like you know that the scrap metal that these people put pickup and floss their
teeth,
which she was just going to stick it right in the juggler.
So finally,
long story short,
she gets the fucking broach off and then we,
we,
we back away
who's like,
ah,
exchange.
Like we like we gave some money briefcase and we got to the abducted kid back
and we fucking walk away.
And I'm like,
Oh fuck.
Thank God.
Thank God that worked out and actually walked back to the,
to the brunch.
All right.
Walk back to the brunch and I got a fucking applause break from like all these
people eating eggs benedict and eggs Florentine.
It was fucking awesome.
How was a Goddamn hero this week?
People,
uh,
scared.
Nervous fucking dude.
I'll tell you Brian,
I didn't come within seven feet of this woman.
I was literally,
you know,
fucking ah,
the avenue out there and I can say where,
cause I don't need psychos known where the fuck I live.
You know,
like I'm anywhere near that level of notoriety.
Uh,
I was literally fucking like,
she's where that wall is over there and we're going,
hey sweetie,
to people who didn't know what was going on,
they probably thought some construction worker hitting on her look in the
fucking games on there.
So,
uh,
yeah,
that was my week.
That was my weak people.
I got my past,
my fucking driver's test and I was a goddamn hero.
Huh?
What did you do this week?
You know what that reminds me of?
What was that Shit he action movie that ended that way.
That started that amazing [inaudible] bitch.
That fucking,
uh,
it's let's to say Brian Johnson.
Brad Pitt's dating.
What's her name?
Natasha wrote Robin Linskey.
She got one of those.
I'm a hot girl names.
What's her name?
Angelina.
You ever seen a fucking ugly girl named Angelina?
Natasha.
Brooke.
That's like a hell of a gamble.
You just know your daughter is,
is his fucking is going to be hot.
Right?
And she's going to go for the money.
She's going for the gold.
So,
uh,
yeah.
What,
what was that movie she did where she was the assassin and the whole movie was
kind of okay.
And then the movie ends with Blah,
blah,
and then it ends.
He goes,
what the fuck did you do today?
Yeah,
no,
not Mrs Mrs. Smith,
who was the one after that?
Morgan Freeman was in it and they stayed,
shoot the gun in the fucking bullet would,
would go,
oh,
this is driving everybody on the podcast and nuts because they know the name of
it.
Well,
the movie basically ends.
He goes,
what the fuck did you do today?
I mean,
did he got pissed?
Hi,
watched a mediocre movie.
Did I say meteoric?
Mediocre?
All right,
whatever.
Go fuck yourselves.
Okay.
This is a what,
35 minutes in 35 minutes.
And this is going to be,
like I said,
it's gonna be a DVD extra.
And if you're watching this,
I probably should've said this earlier.
Maybe we'll do it in the wraparounds now to talk shop.
I was going to say,
where the fuck you can go see this,
get this podcast.
Um,
but here's something new.
For some of you who've actually found my podcast,
which I love at this point,
to actually find my podcast.
It's like a fucking test,
really weeding out the computer illiterate of which I probably couldn't even
find my own podcast unless I,
uh,
if I didn't do it anyways,
we have a new page.
Uh,
it's,
it's
www.themmpodcast.com
www.capitallettersmmpandthenalllowercasepodcast.com.
Uh,
I explained that bad the MMP or all capital letters.
All right,
fuck you.
www.themlmpodcast.com.
Go there.
Um,
I definitely think there'll be some pictures of Leonardo Dicaprio.
I make references to shit.
Sometimes Times people don't know what it is.
The movie that I couldn't remember the name of,
of it's driving you nuts.
That'll be up there.
Uh,
and whatever else I fucking talked about.
And there's,
there's youtube videos and all that type of shit,
um,
of which this week.
You know what?
I don't have any youtube videos.
I've got to admit I was hardcore studying for this impossibly difficult,
um,
test.
What else do I got?
You want me to move again so we can have something different?
Where else would I go?
I went from the,
the,
the Sofa where I was going to go into another room,
but I'm so paranoid.
Then I'm gonna uh,
I got to stand up here for a second.
Maybe I'll be,
I'll be standing up here.
Can you get that?
Can you get that with the camera?
Is this interesting to you people at all?
Oh,
here's one for you.
The conspiracy theory.
Somebody sent me something from,
uh,
from England.
All right,
cause the 14 listeners of my podcast of I'm going in or national with my failure
,
um,
we're saying that in England they're actually experimenting with,
using satellite to catch speeders satellite technology to catch speeders.
Can you fucking believe that?
Somewhere in the middle of that,
I just lost all outrage.
I knew I was fucking pissed.
I stood up and I just realized I was really hungry.
That's so,
that's one of those things that you gotta understand when you're starving to
death.
If you sit down,
it doesn't feel as bad.
You know,
if you ever watched those things when Sally Struthers back in the day you spend
next to those starving kids and what would you see?
They are always sitting down or laying down and you think it's because they're
weak.
It isn't.
They could stand up if they wanted to,
but you just feel hungry.
There's something about your pancreas sort of fills up that spot.
I'll fuck you.
I know.
I don't know what I'm talking about.
Um,
all right,
let's get back to conspiracy theories.
Here's a conspiracy theory.
Somebody sent me this week,
somebody sent me this this week as I put my podcast in my lap,
low level of radiation going into my nuts right now,
know what they should start.
They should make the bottom and like give you some sort of optional lead suit
with these things.
You know?
I think that would be a great thing of Billy Mills was still alive.
If you could make like some sort of cell phone led helmet that comes in like
three different colors,
a manly color color,
a a womanly color,
and then a pattern.
There you go.
And then when it becomes huge,
then you start putting sport logos on it.
Then they do that with the snuggie.
Then you could get like a redskin snuggie for all those people who get cold
while watching football.
Dude,
I'm telling you,
man,
that's how I'm going to parachute out of this fucking business.
I got to come up with some bullshit and just,
you know,
I scream all the time when I do my jokes.
I don't know how to,
I don't know if you ever notice his prime,
but I don't know how to write a joke.
So when I do is I say fuck a lot and I just scream it,
you know,
and then the,
the reverb of me yelling,
you can't hear that.
There was no laughter afterwards.
So I already know how to do the Billy Mays thing.
So all we can do is just come up with some hunk of shit.
All people,
all people.
That's where you got to go.
Do you ever go into the,
I'm going to kill me.
When I went to fucking Dwayne Reed one time and I saw that booster chair for the
toilet seat,
I was just like,
fuck,
that's brilliant.
Yeah.
20 million later that said,
people,
you start in a booster chair and you ended a booster chair.
If you're lucky,
if you don't end in a booster chair,
that means you got hit by a bus and what would you rather do?
Here's a question for you.
Would you rather get hit by a bus at 42 bang and some of the hot ass hardest ass
on the planet,
you know,
or would you rather live to be 70 booster chair in the toilet?
You know,
I've talked about this before,
right?
Your old balls hanging in the toilet water.
That's why they have the booster chairs.
So you're nuts on hit the water.
Oh my God.
Is it the eighties again?
So do one fucking boots to cheers.
Um,
yeah,
this is the podcast.
Let's get onto the next thing.
Uh,
all right.
That was me giving you a little button there.
This is the podcast and we're out.
All right.
Conspiracy the week.
Bill,
you often talk about conspiracies.
Yes,
I do.
Um,
this may or may not fall into that category,
but it definitely pisses me off.
I love this guy already.
I don't know if this is a conspiracy,
but if fucking pisses me off.
Eyeball the eyeball with you so far,
buddy.
All right.
I get my cable and Internet service bundled together from Time Warner last month
with my bill.
I got an a in insert stating that they were modifying their privacy policy.
Basically it states time Warner reserves the right to distribute my internet
content with or without my consent.
From my understanding,
this could mean anything from the searches I requested from Google to the
websites I have been to what rights do we have in this country anymore?
Just venting.
All right dude.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Basically what they've been doing
entire fucking time since the beginning of the Internet is now becoming legal.
So for all you people out there who always thought like,
uh,
like I love when you watch like those,
those talk shows and they talk about,
um,
sexting.
Like you're,
you're,
you're text messaging,
you know,
I want to fuck you from behind or whatever.
Why that sexy?
I have no idea,
you know,
do you think their thumbs tremble but whatever,
I'm not going to judge or like they,
they talk about Skype sex and there'll be like,
why do these people do this?
Why would somebody who had never done,
they always bring a psychologists on,
right?
They always have a beard.
So you know that they majored in psychology,
right?
And then they go,
they always say the same shit and there'll be just like,
well,
it's the,
uh,
anonymity of it.
They,
they,
they feel anonymous.
And in that situation,
they,
they do things that they normally wouldn't done.
Well,
first of all,
people,
it's not anonymous.
You dumb fucks.
It isn't,
they just saying it's anonymous.
They just sent it.
We don't think that they're building a file on you.
So all these fucking morons who've lived the life of the straight and narrow get
on Skype and they stick their junk right in the camera.
You're an idiot.
You're done.
You're already done.
Because they,
they're,
they're building robots right now to re to fucking replace all of us.
And what did you then,
but they're going to keep some of us because somebody got an oil,
they're fucking robot joints.
And what did you do?
You stuck your Dick in the camera yet you processed,
it's over.
It's over.
You gotta take the driver's test.
I won't even fly.
I wouldn't even study.
You're fucking finish.
You're going to get processed.
Just like those people and that fucking movie with that guy who just died.
I can never remember the name.
What's the name of Patrick Swayze was in it?
Blood forced under new America.
What the fuck was it called?
Here come the Russians pissing the radiator.
All that.
All that hatred is gonna.
Gonna gonna eat you up.
Keeps me warm.
Remember that Ed Begley Jr was in it.
No,
he wasn't a fucking,
uh,
the kid who was in Seoul,
man was in it and he shot his friend avenge me.
C'Mon Red Dawn.
Jesus Christ.
Brian,
you're a fucking director.
Do you get that man?
When,
when you get let you live that panic,
that brain panic.
Okay.
You just got it.
Okay,
good.
I thought it was only me.
Uh,
yeah,
absolutely.
No,
this people,
if you want to watch porn like porn,
the porn industry is fucking,
is going through what the music industry is going through right now where all of
a sudden the shit just became free.
All right,
so now everybody's fucking whacking off on the Internet thinking nobody's
watching what you fucking rubbing your shit out too.
They're all watching.
And that building a fucking file.
All right.
You think already,
haven't you noticed why the president's keep getting worse and worse and they
keep fucking getting on their knees and blowing the banks more and more?
It's because of the Internet.
All they gotta do is break out their internet file and show him some of this
shit that they know that they jerked off to.
When it's fights over,
it's fucking over.
You got to do everything that they're going to say they're going to exposure.
They didn't even need to take it in Dallas anymore.
That's old school.
That's why Kennedy got shot in the head.
If there was an internet,
he'd still be walking around and talking right now,
cutting the ribbon at his fucking library,
shitting his pants.
He want to give the eulogy at Fed head Ted's fucking funeral.
Um,
yeah,
so that's,
that's what I'm saying.
Okay.
If you wanna,
if you wanna jerk off to something freaky,
I would say go to a porn store and just deal with the fact that the guy behind
the counter is going to know what you got.
Pay Cash
and walk away.
It's a done deal,
but if you're going to go on the Internet
and do some of this shit that you're doing,
all you can hope now is that you're going to get lost in the shuffle.
Actually,
you can continue to do what you're doing as long as you never try to effect.
If you never try to effectively effect change,
you know what I mean?
That's that's when they break out your Internet file.
Other than that,
it just goes on a fucking database,
but the second you start a movement going,
you know what,
dude,
I'm sick of paying 25 bucks in my first bag when I get on a plane.
If you get enough people behind you United,
well now go to Time Warner and be like,
yeah,
Russell Johnson.
Yeah,
open his file.
What does he jerk?
What's the most fucked up thing?
He's joked often
that is the end of the movement because then Fox News will get it and they'll
just be luck.
Turns out Russell Johnson jerked off to a training in a midget last week.
This was the guy who's going to lead us.
Oh,
don't get me wrong.
I'm doing it,
Glenn Beck.
All right,
let me,
I don't,
oh that fucking guy.
Jesus Christ.
I respect those guys cause they were in show business.
I just wish maybe,
maybe they can't admit that they're in show business.
It's like wrestling.
For the longest time they couldn't say that it was fake.
But now you know,
at some point come on,
just say,
look,
we're doing fake news.
We know.
We know who's gonna win in the end of this shit.
Oh No,
it's all horrible.
All right,
well how much time are we have to have 46 fucking minutes for those of you at
home,
I do 50 minutes every week.
It's a free fucking podcast.
Admit it.
You don't like your job.
Maybe you don't like your wife.
Maybe you don't like yourself.
You need a laugh on a Monday.
I do this for free.
Out of the goodness of my heart.
See that Brian?
I've been a hero every fucking Monday.
Maybe that's what inspired me.
You know what takes it away?
That you can tell that I'm an ally.
I'm a piece of shit.
Cause if I was a true fucking hero,
I wouldn't have told you that story.
I wouldn't have brought it up on the podcast.
It's like a heathen.
I'm praying in public right now.
I should have just done some heroic shit and walked away.
That's when you're bad ass right?
Explosion.
You don't even look at it.
That's what I should've done.
And I didn't.
You know why?
Because I'm a fucking coward and I'm,
I'm fucking blown away by the fact that I,
you know,
Bill,
it was a check you as soon as funny as she weighed like 70 pounds.
That's a funny thing.
But she was crazy.
That's,
that's mental steroids.
When you're crazy,
they can all of a sudden pick you up to the airplane.
Spin like
sergeant slaughter.
Did he do that?
He didn't do that.
Did he?
He had the fucking Cobra Clutch.
All right,
let's wrap this podcast up with um,
the overrated underrated segment.
And this segment is people send in stuff that they feel is overrated or
underrated.
They make a list.
I comment on it and hopefully,
hopefully it's hilarious.
I will tell you what his fucking overrated is buying a God damn shoe rack.
Are you like me?
I eat to the point where your feet have stopped growing.
You don't throw out your fucking sneakers and you've got 58 of them and you've
got shoes and he got boots and all that type of crap.
I've got all of that shit and they were filling up my fucking closet and I'm
like,
all right,
I gotta get one of those shoe racks.
Okay,
but I need one that can hold a bunch of shoes.
Don't look at the picture on the outside of the box because they put fucking
doll shoes on those goddamn racks.
And it looks like you can easily fit three,
four pairs of breasts and then you come home one pair of timberlands and a
fucking flip flop.
And that's a whole level.
Then you can't take it back.
And this whole fucking thing annoyed me.
That's overrated.
Overrated is doing that.
Just leave your sneakers on the fucking floor.
You know what?
Why don't you go down to fucking,
uh,
I was gonna say Grossman's go down to a wire,
the,
the Home Depot and build your own shoe rack for a fucking adult.
I'm literally sweating in my own apartment here.
I'm Amy.
I'm not going to be sweaty on the podcast.
That Comey,
who is that?
Who's this guy for those people at home?
Huh?
Who is that guy?
Remember that coach?
I don't remember his coach either,
but he coached the team out in Vegas.
Some of the teeth.
It looks like an old Elmer.
Fudd like Elmer Fudd fucked on.
Zimmer.
That's what he looked like.
Jesus.
I was insulting.
All right.
Here's one from somebody underrated.
Uh,
Quincy,
the show,
the Fonz and Sam alone get all the credit for getting the ladies.
But Quincy got just as much as any of them.
It seemed like he had a different chicken is on his houseboat.
Every episode.
He was basically a silent assassin.
The best part of it is that he used the word broad to refer to the ladies.
Those were different times.
They really were.
They really were a Jack Klugman is Quincy.
That was like a,
that was the end of an era.
Remember that Brian?
You ever hear like,
yeah,
when we were growing up,
they the the casting couch when guys ran this fucking business and now look,
you know what's funny is they taught a fifth day.
If the ladies,
if they ran it,
that they were there,
it would be,
it would be better,
but it isn't.
It's just is unbalanced the other fucking direction.
Now you've got a bunch of pussies on TV who are afraid of their wives.
You know,
Ralph Kramden used to threaten every week.
That's what I loved about that show because they still shown them being a moron,
but he's still physically intimidated.
You know,
like Larry Johnson,
he had that power forward respect on that show.
That's all I'm looking for.
Just show a guy in a relationship was getting a little bit of fucking respect,
you know?
All right,
I'm going over my time here.
The last thing we're going to talk about as bad covers.
I talked last week,
ah,
somebody,
Mary j Blige to the cover of a stairway to heaven and a whole lot of love.
It wasn't bad,
but you know what I mean?
I Dunno.
It's just one of those things where there's some,
some music.
It's just sacred.
It's sacred to you.
So no matter how talented somebody is a you like,
what the fuck?
So I was talking to last really bad cover that I heard that it just really,
it just annoyed the shit out of me.
Well actually I was in a gym in somebody's had remixed are shit,
did the remix of a
sympathy for the devil by the rolling stones.
You know,
and I'm going to go out on a limb,
I think Mick Keith and the guy,
I think they got it right the first fucking time.
These fucking assholes,
first of all,
first thing they do is they edit out the guitar solo.
Okay.
Take Keith Guitar Solo out.
And then at one point,
literally dropped out everything other than Mick,
Mick Jagger's voice,
and then had some new updated like,
like a Casio drum beat underneath it.
It was just,
Ugh,
it's just a fucking worst Scott Damn Song I've ever heard.
Jesus Christ.
Bill.
How did I not make that funny?
I really bombed with that.
Like I started off,
it was decent.
I got lost in the middle of it.
You know,
I got freaked out.
I was like,
what if Mary j actually buys this fucking DVD?
I,
I went to that arrogance space.
You know what it was.
You know what happened there,
Brian?
I cared.
And the whole fucking thing went away.
All right,
let's see here.
The last bad cover.
Um,
this here's one from somebody,
and I know this,
this,
this actually a segment is starting to blow up.
I just didn't have time to put everybody,
so don't,
uh,
everybody's bad covers on there.
I want to read these because you guys really came up with some great ones this
week.
Um,
here's one that he says a,
all right,
this,
the cover,
the cover song that pissed me off the most has to be slash in Fergie's slash in
Fergie from the black eyed peas featuring that dude from Cypress hill there.
They actually redid paradise city.
And uh,
right there I was immediately going,
oh no.
Oh No.
And he says all that energy and swagger on the of the original,
everything that made that song a bonafide classic is ruined in this version.
Anyone that really holds up slash is a god and trashes axel cannot honestly sit
there and tell me that this song does mortar ruin guns and roses name than the
Chinese democracy.
What a horrible,
infuriating idea.
Please,
please give this song.
That's the treatment it deserves on your podcast.
I gotta admit,
I am a fucking huge is how big a fan of I am of slash like I was right with them
slash a snake pit.
I saw velvet revolver,
anything he does,
I will go fucking see.
I remember I saw Joe Perry project and he showed up and he played with the band.
It was fucking awesome.
I love slash but I got to tell you this one that I'm not trashing slash year
because even Dinero has made some bad fucking movies.
But uh,
here it is.
You guys want to hear a little,
I'll,
I'll play,
I'll just a little bit of this and I'm actually not worried about slash seeing
this because we won't have the rights to play this on the DVD.
So here you go.
Um,
I think it's been a really nice podcast this week.
and you should appreciate it,
especially a free podcast from a hero such as myself.
I just like saying that.
It's so fucking annoying.
Hey,
what are you doing?
Well,
I'm a comedian and also I'm a hero.
I'm a fucking hero.
Uh,
as long as they're
crazy women and they weigh less than 70 pounds,
I am right there to do my duty as,
as,
as a,
as a stand up citizen.
So here it is everybody.
Everybody have a great week.
Thanks for listening to the podcast and we're going to close out with the,
the Paradise City 2.0,
I'll play a little bit of this shit.
Uh,
this is slash Fergie from the black eyed peas and that guy from Cypress Hill,
you know the,
the fucking trio that we've all been waiting for for years.
They finally came together and here's what it sounds like.
Yeah.
Dude.
What the fuck already?
[inaudible]
right here.
You're going,
okay.
Maybe they're going to save it.
[inaudible]
ah,
AH,
enough.
Oh my God.
Oh my God dude.
You ever get like fucking embarrassed for somebody else?
What the fuck?
You know,
I,
I hate,
I can't see why to rappers always have to let you know who the fuck is in the
building.
I can read the liner notes.
We got had slaves in the hell.
I know he wrote it.
The Duchess Fergie.
Ah,
that,
that that is,
yeah,
that one didn't bug me as much as led Zeppelin.
I have to admit like,
cause when,
when guns [inaudible] roses,
when they came out,
I was like 1920 already realize I could see myself becoming a loser.
It's sent music that you loved when you had hope,
you know,
speaking of which is one for my,
my childhood,
I hope for a speedy recover for our Bret Michaels man.
Seriously,
man,
I know a lot of people,
uh,
may,
may or may not like fucking poison,
whatever.
You've got to hand it to the guy.
They stuck around for 25 fucking years and dies in the hospital right now.
So I hope that guy,
uh,
comes out better than fucking ever.
And,
uh,
that's it.
See,
that's what a hero does.
He brings it around,
or a nice moment.
That's the,
uh,
that's a podcast for this week.
Please tune in next week.
Please keep all the,
um,
the questions,
comments,
and all that stuff coming.
I really appreciate it.
Have a great week.
And,
uh,
that's it.
And take it easy.
[inaudible].